la idea de este vídeo es poderles
mostrar que la derivación implícita y la
derivación explícita es justo la misma
es decir la derivada que siempre
conocíamos y la derivada que vimos en el
vídeo pasado es la misma y para eso me
voy a tomar una función en la cual yo
pueda despejar fácilmente la jr
tengo la función x que multiplica a la
raíz de y es igual a 1 y bueno pues
despejemos a la variable y entonces me
queda que la raíz de y es igual a 1
entre x la x la estoy pasando dividiendo
y después voy a elevar al cuadrado ambos
miembros de esta igualdad por lo tanto
no queda que es igual a 1 entre x
cuadrada o dicho de otra manera y es
igual a x elevado a la menos 2 y
calcular la derivada de esto es muy
sencillo lo podemos hacer por la regla
de la potencia entonces me queda que la
derivada de ella con respecto a x es
igual a menos 2 bajo el exponente y el
exponente le restó 1 - 2x la menos 3
bueno por la derivada normal que
nosotros sabemos llegamos a este
resultado ahora lo que quiero mostrarles
es que si derivamos implícitamente
también
vamos a llegar al mismo resultado así
que para esto tomemos el operador
derivada de ambos lados de la relación y
me queda que la derivada con respecto a
x de x que multiplica a la raíz de james
es igual a la derivada con respecto a x
de 1 y bueno aquí tengo la derivada con
respecto a x de una multiplicación de
funciones por lo tanto para resolver
esto nosotros teníamos una fórmula que
decía primero deriva una multiplicada
por la segunda y sumarle la derivada de
la segunda y multiplicada por la primera
entonces voy a hacer esta regla que dice
la derivada de una multiplicación de
funciones es la derivada de la primera
función en este caso es x y esto
multiplicado por la segunda función que
es raíz de james + la primera función
tal cual no le hacíamos nada y la
multiplicamos por la derivada de la
segunda función a la derivada con
respecto a x la segunda función que es
raíz de y entonces es la derivada con
respecto a x de la raíz de james y esto
va a ser igual a la derivada con
respecto a x de uno pero uno es una
constante por lo tanto la derivada de
una constante es
y hasta aquí vamos todo bien ahora vamos
a realizar las correspondientes
derivadas la derivada con respecto a x
de x pues eso es muy sencillo esto es 1
y que multiplica a la raíz de jaymee
queda simple y sencillamente la raíz de
y por lo tanto que me queda la raíz de
james
porque recuerda que multiplicar por 1 es
no hacer nada por lo tanto no queda en
la raíz de james ya esto hay que
agregarle x que multiplica a la derivada
con respecto a x de la raíz de ye y para
resolver esta segunda derivada que yo
tengo aquí voy a usar la regla de la
cadena entonces es más x aquí lo voy a
poner que multiplica a esta derivada
pero entonces vamos a resolver esta
derivada aparte para ver qué es lo que
nos sale si utilizamos la regla de la
cadena cuál es la derivada con respecto
a x de la raíz de y recuerden que ya es
una función que depende de x por lo
tanto las necesitamos derivar con mucha
calma tenemos que bajar el exponente que
es un medio un medio que multiplica a
elevada a la un medio menos 1 esto que
acabamos de hacer es la derivada de la
raíz de ye con respecto a la misma para
que no se confundan lo voy a poner aquí
con mucha calma para que vean que es lo
mismo la derivada con respecto a x de la
raíz de x es lo mismo que la derivada
x elevada a la un medio por lo tanto
bajamos el exponente me queda un medio
que multiplica a x elevada a la un medio
menos 1 es decir a la menos un medio y
es por esa razón que tenemos que la
derivada con respecto a jeff de la raíz
de james es esto que tenemos aquí ya
esto hay que multiplicarlo por la regla
de la cadena por la derivada de ella con
respecto a x es decir nos acaba esto
aquí es un medio que multiplica a ye
elevada a la menos un medio que a su vez
multiplica a la derivada de ya con
respecto a x ojo esto es por la regla de
la cadena y realmente esto no es tan
difícil lo único que hay que hacer es
derivar las funciones que dependen de y
con respecto a ayer y siempre
multiplicarlo por la derivada del día
con respecto a x y esto va a ser igual a
0 no se te olvide siempre que derive
algo con respecto a y multiplicar al
final por la derivada de y con respecto
a x este es el consejo que te puedo dar
y bueno ahora lo que quiero es despejar
la derivada de y con respecto a x para
que yo pueda poner todo en términos de y
después en términos de x para ver si son
iguales
voy a hacer magia y dice algo si
seleccionas y ahora lo ven ahora no lo
ven y ahora lo ven otra vez muy bien
corte y pegue todo esto para tener un
poco más de espacio pero creo que lo voy
a regresar mejor a donde estaba si no no
para que trabaje todo hacia abajo ok ya
lo tengo otra vez aquí y ahora lo que
voy a hacer es despejar a la derivada de
ye con respecto a x para ver que en
efecto nos dé la misma cosa por lo tanto
lo que voy a hacer es restar de ambos
lados de la ecuación la raíz de y y
además lo que voy a hacer es acomodar
esto de una manera que sea mucho más
fácil escribirla porque yo tengo x que
multiplica a un medio que sube
multiplica ai elevada a la menos un
medio y esto es lo mismo que x entre dos
veces la raíz de james x por unas x el 2
queda abajo y elevado a la menos un
medio es lo mismo que la raíz de y abajo
dividiendo y esto multiplica a su vez a
la derivada de ye con respecto a x y la
raíz de yebla voy a pasar del otro lado
con signo negativo
y como me hace falta espacio lo que voy
a hacer ahora sí es pasar esto para
arriba para continuar con lo que estaba
haciendo y lo que estoy haciendo
realmente lo que quiero es despejar a la
derivada de ya con respecto a x
recuerden que atrás de eso vamos
entonces aquí tengo a x entre dos veces
la raíz de ye que está multiplicando a
la derivada de ye con respecto a x por
lo tanto si yo quiero despejar a la
derivada de ye con respecto a x tengo
que pasar del otro lado la x entre dos
veces la raíz de y sin embargo esto es
un quebrado
esta es una fracción por lo tanto la
puedo pasar del otro lado como su
recíproca es decir dos veces la raíz de
james entre x y esto a su vez va a
multiplicar a la menos raíz de yen
y esto fue porque pasamos la fracción
del otro lado y ahora si dos veces la
raíz de y por menos raíz de ye es menos
dos veces james y esto hay que dividirlo
entre equis y ahora si ya tenemos que la
derivada de ella con respecto a x
despejada es igual a menos 2 entre x y
bueno seguramente vas a decir pero no
llegamos al mismo resultado que pasó
aquí yo tengo que la derivada de ya con
respecto a x es igual a menos 12 x a la
menos 3 y aquí tengo que es menos 2 y
entre x donde queda la y dónde queda el
x la menos 3 que puedo hacer sin embargo
no te olvides que aquí ya habíamos
despejado ayer por lo tanto lo que hay
que hacer es sustituir ayer en la
segunda igualdad es decir esto nos va a
quedar de la siguiente manera la
derivada de ye con respecto a x es igual
a menos 2 veces
jeff pero ya era 1 / x cuadrada por lo
tanto me queda menos 2 veces uno entre x
cuadrada lo voy a poner de amarillo para
que no nos perdamos menos 2 que
multiplica a 1 entre x cuadrada ya esto
hay que dividirlo entre
y ahora si esto es lo mismo que menos 2
/ x al cubo esto por la ley del sándwich
y por cierto es lo mismo que menos 2
veces x elevada a lo menos 3 lo logramos